[Music]
hello thank you
only ET was invited into Real Housewives
of Orange County star Kelly Dodds
beachfront home for one last tour before
she moves out in a few weeks there are
some changes that are happening in my
personal life that I'm sure everyone is
heard but the house was already you were
already selling it before all that was
in the works you correct yes we were our
tour comes just days after Kelly
announced she is filing for divorce from
her husband of 11 years Michael who was
actually at the home during our visit
was there a final straw that finally
went on now it's time no I just just I
guess everyone has a final straw I just
it was just you know it's just not
working so it was like just
disagreements all the time and you'll
see it work out on camera on on filming
you just continue to watch and you'll
see how everything is good and then just
like a hardcore left and okay and that's
probably really what the course of my
relationship is like with Michael it's
either good or really bad and in the
show if you continue to watch you'll see
that okay well good yes and all that
yeah and you guys are still on good
terms I'm still friends just have a
daughter together right we're really
good friends so it's an amicable yeah
he's he's um you know he's my family
part of my family he always will be and
you know I always want him in my life
and so we always want to do things
together with Julie and it's just we
just can't live together that's it got
it yeah better as friends the better as
friends yes I like this it's a new
chapter in my life which I am pretty
excited yeah what are you most excited
about for the new chapter just you know
I'm spending like one-on-one time with
my daughter you know starting my
business getting just really focus focus
on Kelly just getting focus on Kelly
yeah yeah
[Music]